black lines matter demonstrations over
the summer at times were pretty intense
protesters outraged over the killing of
george floyd an unarmed black man killed
in police custody
all this week we're examining what
changes metro police have made and what
still needs work
bianca holman shares how black officers
are straddling the line
black police officers are in the middle
they serve the valley in uniform but are
frustrated with the disproportionate
number of unarmed black people
killed by police black officers say they
faced
challenges on the job and in the
community when it comes to their race
however the black police officers
association bpoa
is a way they're breaking down barriers
to confront racism
in recent years the organization hosted
community events to help
build relationships and trust president
regina coward-holman says
if metro's mission is to serve people in
need then they must be held accountable
building bridges
and being the conscience of the justice
system we see something that's wrong
we have to found the bill we have to
speak up we can no longer just sit back
like these things didn't happen
tonight at 11 we'll look at the advisory
council that's in place to provide
feedback to the sheriff
how much of metro staff is
african-american and those officers
ideas on how to improve the force
reporting bianca holman 8 news now